c'est un monde de cruauté et de misère
que révèlent leur rapport sur
l'esclavagé des enfants remis cette
année encore à l'oni enfants livrés à la
prostitution forcée à la servitude des
travaux les plus durs ou conduit sur le
fond c'est la chronique de la honte que
déclinent ce document officiel plus
horrible encore le commerce au paraguay
et de nouveau-nés achetés par les états
unis probablement pourri alimenter des
banques d'organes
jérôme baugnies françois dans des
semaines enfin vendu par leurs propres
parents
gamine livrer à la prostitution ces
experts de la commission des droits de
l'homme de l'onu sont chargés d'analyser
scientifiquement et de compiler les
aspects les plus sordides de l'humanité
eu pourtant ne vont pas sur le terrain
pour des raisons politiques
ils doivent s'en remettre à des
organisations non gouvernementales comme
la société anti esclavagiste qui lutte
notamment contre le travail des enfants
en inde dans les carrières de pierre ou
la fabrication de tapis une journée de
12 peut-être fonder une décision très
malsaine 100 m son lumière ils
développent des maladies tuberculose
surtout hawk maladie des gens
et du corps la société anti esclavagiste
estime à 45 millions le nombre d'enfants
travaillant en inde dans le monde
ils seraient quelques 200 millions
s'épuisant le plus souvent à des tâches
particulièrement dur pourtant ils sont
paradoxalement considérés comme des
privilégiés par ceux qui faute de
travail sont livrés eux aux plaisirs
interdits de riches étrangers en
thaïlande ou aux philippines
chloé nul ne peut pas grand chose contre
ces pratiques clandestines
pas plus que contre le recrutement
d'enfants dans les armées de pays
siégeant à eux mêmes à la commission des
droits de l'homme
les experts des nations unies ont appris
à modérer leurs ambitions les
possibilités sont toujours très limité
il y as on ne peut pas toujours faire
des choses très efficace il ya les
gouvernements et le souveraineté des
états et l'onu après tout c'est une
organisation des gouvernements il ne
faut pas l'oublier
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui au palais
des nations de cette affaire de trafic
de bébés au paraguay à des fins de
greffe d'organes une autre affaire
similaire a été évoqué la semaine
dernière pendant le groupe de travail en
haïti
mais dans ces affaires il n'y a pas de
preuve formelle est ici à l'onu on aime
bien travailler sur du concret et puis
il faut bien le reconnaître on travaille
avec des moyens limités et face à ce
genre de trafic
l'organisation ne peut guère faire plus
que de demander à interpol de redoubler
de vigilance